good afternoon thank you so much for
joining us on this beautiful fall day
just before the the midterm elections
that we're going to be talking about
today I'm Jacob hacker I direct the
institution for social and policy
studies the building in which you are
now located is the is the home of the
center and I'm really pleased that we
have a distinguished panel to talk about
the elections before i start i want to
offer some thanks i want to thank first
a pointer institute for journalism which
made it possible for us to bring in
Natalie Jackson whom all introduced in a
moment I'd like to thank Pam green for
the heroic efforts she made to make this
work despite the fact we caused her a
little bit of a heart attack by saying
at the end that we wanted to just blast
out more invites and she said oh my god
well we have too many people not enough
food people in the aisle and I said
that's good it's good when you run out
of the food it's good when you have
people in the aisle and still feel free
to eat up and then finally I want to
thank our panelists and I'll introduce
them my goal is to say as little as
possible here which if for those who you
know me is difficult so i will i'll try
to i'll try to restrain myself and
introduce our really distinguished
panelist from right to left there's no
political meaning implied here we have
David Mayhew he's someone who needs no
introduction but as one of my less
modest mentor said needs no introduction
but always appreciates one so he is a
distinguished scholar of Congress he's a
sterling professor which is a very big
deal he's the author of so many books I
can't possibly name them but his his
tenure book the book that got in tenure
was Congress the electoral connection
which continues to sell thousands of
copies a year and is probably the most
influential book written on Congress in
the modern era Woodrow Wilson I think
might you know have a little bit of a
little bit of a challenge to him if you
go back farther from no he did not know
Woodrow Wilson though he probably knows
exactly the election returns
Wilson in every state of the union ok so
moving to the left we have a time Hirsch
a time is our as our young election guru
he is not only a distinguished scholar
but also someone who has been very adept
at getting access to and involved with
political campaigns not as an advocate
but as an analyst one of the great
achievements is his work and bringing 22
political scientist catalyst which you
may talk a little bit about it which is
the Democrats get out the vote database
it's pretty remarkable and includes all
registered voters in the United States
and thus there know as close as we're
going to have to a big data data set on
elections and then finally all the way
the left is Natalie Jackson who's
joining us who's coming to us from New
York she actually lives in Hyde Park so
and she she's been working with the with
Huffington Post to refine their polling
techniques she was previously working
with the marist poll she has a PhD in
political science but she's also done a
postdoc from Oklahoma but she's also
done a postdoctoral work at Duke and
she's really an expert on data science
and research and pulling methodology and
is going to speak to us a little bit
about not just the Huffington Post model
but the more general task of modeling
elections okay that was definitely more
than I wanted to say and so I am going
to let each of our panelists give a few
brief introductory remarks and and then
I'll open it up to a little bit of
exchanged among us but mostly I would
like to get out to you and to get your
questions about this imminent midterm so
thanks again for coming and enjoy the
event so to my left David make you know
but David will not start because we
agreed this is why you guys should have
sat in the other direction natalie
natalie is going to start us off okay so
as you have probably seen there are lots
of people out there trying to predict
which direction the Senate is going to
go primary concern is the Senate because
it's what could switch majority parties
the house we all know is probably going
to stay Republican in fact the
Republicans are likely to gain some
seats depending on which forecast you
look at and but the Senate is really up
in the air at this point if you look
right now we're four days out from the
election and across all the various
forecasting models that are being put
out by media organizations the lowest
the highest percentage chance of a
republican takeover is the washington
post with 93% but everyone else is in
the 60's range so there's not a lot of
certainty on what's going to happen
there are a lot of seats up for grabs
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
modeling structures and we have some
challenges that are unique and the
huffington post model says we have about
a sixty-three percent chance of the
senate going republican as of right now
that could change later this afternoon
our model constantly updates every time
we get a new poll it'll rerun that
particular state and put it back through
the model right now it's about sixty
three percent and that's been fairly
steady for the last week or so in fact
we've never since we launched the model
we've never had either party as more
than sixty to sixty-five percent certain
of having a majority so the moral of the
overall forecast is kind of flip a coin
we're a little bit better than a coin
flip now getting into the 60s but a
sixty percent probability is still
significant room for things to go the
other way some of the challenges that we
face with forecasting this that are
unique to midterms and unique to this
particular midterm are inherent in just
looking at state by state probabilities
you know trying to factor in polling
does
the national mood matter does what
people think of Obama matter and some of
the forecasts New York Times 538
Washington Post they pull in some of
these other factors Huffington Post and
Daily ko's and I believe Princeton
election consortium models are polls
only we try to make some adjustments so
that the polls only are reflective of
what we think the environment is but the
idea is that the polling generally
captures what the national mood is so
there's no need to add that in in a
different stage of the model we'll see
who is right or we're all running pretty
close right now so it's hard to say that
anyone would be a definitive winner on
the polling side though we have some
interesting questions of how do you
predict turnout have you know who's
actually going to vote and in 2010
interestingly all of the polls
significantly under represented Democrat
turnout so the average was 3.1
percentage points in several of our
really close races that Republicans are
leading right now we're well within that
margin so if the polls are under
estimating turnout in any systematic way
we could have very wrong forecasts we're
also dealing with a lot of changing
demographics you'll hear about these
particularly in states like Colorado and
we have issues with states that aren't
pulled very much like Alaska and Kansas
they don't see much polling in an
average year and Kansas wouldn't have
this year except that at the beginning
of September we had a candidate suddenly
drop out so then everybody's scrambling
to go into Kansas to poll so are they is
good at polling some of these other
states as the states that are more
commonly pulled and we do have pollsters
that pop up and disappear and one
recently this cycle called optimist
showed up and we saw one thing and we we
couldn't find any information about the
firm
then they just disappeared so we have a
lot of things to consider when we're
looking at constructing this type of
forecast and a lot of it is focused on
the immediate context and figuring out
how the immediate context is informed by
patterns that we've seen historically
but yet allowing for the fact that it's
probably going to be a little bit
different and so I'll wrap up there
quick follow-up because we you said the
difficulty of dem occur of predicting
demo what's going to happen a certain
sort of merging demographic groups if
you will is that mostly a contacting
problem that we think that they're
harder to reach or is it just that we
haven't factored that into our sort of
historically based models it's kind of
both um in Alaska they're very difficult
to reach and that's one of the primary
problems we see in polling in Alaska is
getting to people in Colorado it the
discussion is about Latino voters and in
that case it can also be a contact issue
because of language barriers great hey
wait Thank You having me I'm going to
start by saying to brief comments about
voter turnout in this election one about
the United States Senate what about the
house of representatives in the Senate
as we all know there's about 10 centers
that are closed which is which is really
amazing about third of the Senate is you
know is up for grabs I mean a third of
the elections that are contested are up
for grabs that that's exciting and if we
get one thing wrong about these Senate
races it might be that we're getting
turn out wrong especially on the
Democratic side so one thing that both
parties agree about is that the
Democrats are better at the grassroots
mobilization through the Obama years
they've built up a big infrastructure
good technology a lot of on to your
capacity to do grassroots mobilization
at the end of the election right now
from now until Tuesday door knocking and
things like that and the the important
thing knows people who right now or in
the last six months are self-reported
non vote
meaning they pick up the phone and
someone pulls them and and they're asked
are you likely to vote they say no then
the polish that pollster says okay
thanks very much you know goodbye
because we're interested in polling
likely voters those people are not in
samples are not going to be in pulling
samples so if the Democrats advantage on
grassroots mobilization is real and if
they can use that to overcome a lack of
enthusiasm for this year's election then
that those Democrats won't be showing up
in the polls yet and if we see come
Tuesday more Democrats winning then then
all the polling is suggesting this might
be the main this certainly in terms of
media I think will be the main thing
that folks are paying attention to and
will indeed I think be an important
component of what's going on so if the
polls are wrong and Democrats do a
little bit better than expected this
might be the reason what's interesting
is the Republicans are the first to
admit that they are weaker on on this
front if of course the if the
Republicans win by a lot then you know I
think we'll learn a little bit more
about and you know even though even
though the grassroots mobilization
efforts are only only supposed to get an
extra one or two or three percentage
points of the votes it's really hard to
overcome a lack of enthusiasm so there
might be a story after election about
this on the house side as we know like
no one's paying attention the house the
house is totally uninteresting the
Republicans are going to keep it so what
is interesting about the house I think
the one thing to pay attention to that
is interesting about this house is a
fluke that happened in 2012 now most
recent house election we had a fluke the
fluke is that the Democrats got the
majority of the house votes and lost the
seats right so Democrats got 50.5 or
something percent of the votes but only
forty-six percent of the seats this can
happen in any legislature because the
people are distributed in weird ways
throughout the country so that some
districts have very different
populations in other districts David and
I were spending the last month or so
going back and forth about this question
about when's the last time it happened
it turns out sort of a complicated
question but it happened a little bit in
1952 maybe happened in 1942 but it
hasn't happened in a long time and it
is concerning and it's concerning in
part because of its relationship to
gerrymandering and redistricting okay so
the main reason why this kind of thing
can happen in 2012 why we think it
happened is that a lot of voters were
coming out for the presidential election
in in democratic districts that were
super highly democratic districts like
majority minority districts where you
know a huge percent of the electorate
was voting for Obama and therefore for
the house candidate on the Democratic
side and so the Democrats had a lot of
wasted votes in these very safe seats in
part because Democrats are just
concentrated in urban populations and in
part because in states that Republicans
for drawing the district lines they
pushed a lot of Democrats into highly
democratic districts in order to get
more seats across the country so in 2014
is this likely to happen probably not
because we're not going to probably see
as high turnout in in in the the big
Obama supporting districts but if it
does happen right then we'll think more
about the explanations related to
gerrymandering and so if if there's a
there's a repeat in Democrats getting it
doesn't have to be them it doesn't have
to be more votes and seats doesn't like
the majority of votes but if they get if
if the swing ratio which is what we call
the relationship between have seats and
votes is out of whack by a lot then I
think there's more reason to be
concerned about the relationship between
gerrymandering and and vote share and
see chair in the house so those are the
two things that i would pay attention to
on the house and senate side
a very quick question which is do you
think that an offsetting factor given
the Democrats advantage in last-minute
voter mobilization is the new wave of
voter ID laws or is that not going to
really affect the elections this year I
don't think it's going to affect the
elections this year because so far we
haven't had a lot of evidence of
decreasing turnout from the ID laws and
there is this hypothesis that the ID
laws in themselves are mobilizing forces
for the Democrats because Democrats get
angry about them and the other thing is
that we don't have you know where the
voter ID laws are going into effect
suddenly like in Texas is not you know a
state that were that focused on so great
David a little bit of history before
Obama we've had six presidents in the
last century who served two full terms
and they've got elected the first time
and then endure the midterm and then got
reelected that endured a second midterm
these are wilson FDR who actually served
the third term Wilson as I say FDR
Eisenhower Reagan Clinton and Bush 43
there are three Republicans and three
Democrats in all of these instances the
president who took over at the beginning
of the two terms succeeded a president
of the opposite party so in all cases
you get a fresh deck so as if some
interest at least for kicks to see what
the electoral history and beyond that
the policy history is of these two term
presidencies our Obama we're going to
have presumably the seventh two-term
presidency but I'm talking about the
sixth that preceded him and in all cases
if you look at party shares that the
president's party enjoys in the house
and the Senate the record over the first
to the second through the third through
the fourth Congress not surprisingly is
sharply down across all the four there's
another it varies and its sharpness as
it goes down but it goes down there's a
slope across and it doesn't differ by
party it goes down across these
presidencies and when you get to the
fourth Congress that is to say that
Congress after the second midterm which
we're about to have another one of in
five of the
cases a president is looking at a house
and a Senate controlled by the
opposition party our house and a Senate
controlled by the opposition party the
only exception in the six is FDR who
after his second midterm still did face
a Democratic Congress both House and
Senate but it was a miserable time for
FDR after the 1938 midterm I mean the
conservative conservative coalition was
largely dominating the Congress and we
had hostile investigations in the
National NLRB of the Communists and the
agencies the Smith alien registration
act the Hatch Act controlling what
federal employees can do and so far
they're very grim time for FDR during
that fourth Congress oh it didn't serve
them an awful lot of good that the
Democrats still hello Congress in that
fourth after that second midterm so
really it's there it is in five cases
the party she is in both houses go to
the other side and Roosevelt's case it's
Grove anyway now the history actually
across the two terms vary somewhat the
electoral history on the house side as
opposed to the Senate side and as
interesting variation there it's down in
both cases across the four Congress's
but the interesting variation on the
house side what happens on average and
you understand this is average you know
this is an envelope there no question
about it but if I took by this this by
the way to Congress to president's party
controlling for 68 years even when it's
not just one person and soph what the
pattern wouldn't differ that much I'm
just zeroing in and what I'm doing
though just for just for neatness on the
house side what happens is the
president's party tends to lose about 30
seats in the first midterm and then hold
even and then lose another 30 seats in
the second midterm so there are two
exercises of grimness for a presidential
party in the midterms midterms are just
plain bad news for president's party in
Obama's case the Democrats already lost
an exceptional number of House seats in
their first midterm so they're probably
not going to lose very more it's pretty
close to the bottom of the barrel maybe
another ten maybe another 15 or so but
it's not going to be 30 if they're going
to lose this time unless astonishing
things happened during the next week
nobody expects on the Senate side is
different on the Senate side the
president's party in the first midterm
that's pretty well
as a president's party on average keeps
as many Senate seats in the first
midterm as they had going into the first
vid term so it's a pretty good shape
going into its second Congress okay and
then the president's party also stays
pretty well it's kind of an even keel
and the president's reelect so it's
typical for a president's party to have
pretty good Senate holdings in the first
the second and the third Congress but
then what happens is that the
president's party gets hammered in the
second midterm that's a history that's
the history and this hammered as an
average of seven seat loss a seven-seat
loss in the second midterm over the
previous Congress for the president's
party and there is a tricky reason for
this says what happens in senate
elections will be dominated at least to
some degree by the fact that these folks
got elected six years earlier so right
now we're looking at democrats who got
elected six years earlier when obama
took the presidency from the republicans
and had some coattails you remember the
two thousand eight election so that
exposes these folks now in 2014 and also
for that matter if I'm not going to play
it out but the same kind of logic it
obtains with the first midterm when the
president's party does pretty well I
mean six years before that was a
presidential lecture where the opposite
party took the White House and I'm not
going to play it out it's kind of
complicated but if you think about it
you can do it so now the actually come
to think of it the the the Obama party
and four years ago in 2010 actually
their Muslim Senate seats they did it
was a bad year you'll recall in two
thousand time for the Democrats even
though they took they kept the Senate
they lost six secrets not great but on
average over the over the odds they say
in this potted pocket history you'd
expect some losses now of course whether
they whether the whether the Democrats
go under the oil and we just don't know
we certainly don't know but i would say
at least it's a fair to say that the
holdings will go down will go down into
the end of the 50 70 at a 50-50 range so
the sum however they somehow the age of
harry reid is probably over i mean if
the democrats lose four seats rather
than seven or eight seats still it's
going to be an interesting mess as
organizing the Senate once the senate
comes in and january you've got you have
renegade democrats in
dependence and I just can't imagine joe
Manchin of West Virginia conceding
agenda control of the Senate if he's the
marginal person who makes a Democratic
majority bless Joe Biden come January of
two thousand and 2015 there we are the
only other thing I want to say is this
to finish it off and hear the point is
not just about what happened during
these six presidencies but about all
midterms and all presidential elections
or all presidential year congressional
elections as well as mid team your
midterm year congressional elections
since World War two somebody did a study
I think this is authoritative it looked
like 1948 three 2004 asking your
question do Democrats still worse in
congressional elections on average and
Bo Ginn vote shares in the midterm years
than they do in the presidential years
the answer is no there's no difference
in the vote share Democratic vote share
in the congressional elections and the
midterms as opposed to the congressional
elections in the presidential years
there's just nothing nothing there
there's also no relation of that half
century period between turnout in the
congressional elections or whatever they
occurred and democratic party vote share
if there is a wreck this is a different
point out if there is a regularity out
there that maybe the following this has
been written about by Sam crudele the
political scientists it's that in the
midterms there is an asymmetry in the
midterms it's that the antes tend to get
more heated up to the pros that is the
opposition party tends to get more
passionate and get his people out that
does the pro party that's got the
presidency that seems to be a regularity
at least occur it's often enough so that
it probably affects what happens in
midterms that's it that's a lot thank
you David okay so first of all I want to
ask if any of the panelists David
probably accepted although who knows he
may have more wants to comment on any of
the the trends or issues discussed so
far before I ask any more questions hey
Don okay so I think the one thing that
um that we haven't talked about and then
I think everyone here would be
interested in is what difference the
election might make so granting that
we're going to see a modest loss to four
Democrats in the house and this question
the question remains of whether or not
the Senate will remain in democratic
hands and we might want to throw in here
what is happening at the gubernatorial
level as well what do people for see and
you can do this conditional on the
Senate control as the pattern of the
next two years and David of course you
can ground that in your ear historical
comparison so Natalie starting with you
what are your predictions as far as the
Senate goes I honestly don't see that
much will change even if the Republicans
do get the majority simply because we
still have a president that has to sign
every bill into law and there's a little
bit of talk now that a lot of the
forecasts are settling in that the
Republicans probably will take the
majority then the discussion kicks up
well can they get to 60 and they can't
there's no there's no statistical way
that they can get to 60 seats they'd
have to have at least three of the very
heavily Democratic seats that are up for
election completely flip and the chances
of that happening is well under one
percent so they're not going to get a
supermajority the all of the leadership
will change will see different types of
bills going through obviously but as far
as things actually being enacted into
policy I don't I see any break in the
gridlock that we've already seen and as
for you mentioned the governor's side
that is probably an underrated place
where we will see policy change there
are 12 very very close governor races
right now and some of them are in states
you wouldn't expect Connecticut's one of
them and
Florida is running very close of course
you kind of expect that one but a lot of
these places that would be complete
switchovers from what they've seen
before so that's probably the place the
state level is the place where I'd look
for more policy change depending on a
lot of these gubernatorial elections
this might be the obvious thing but I
think the the most obvious and important
thing that will happen depending on
Senate controls the judicial
appointments so probably no Supreme
Court stuff happening in the next two
years probably but a heck of a lot of
appellate and district court judges that
could be nominated and those nominations
will take a very different flavor to
them depending on who has control the
Senate especially now we have the
nuclear or nuclear option depending on
your party affiliation in effect right
where the Senate is is is putting
through these nominations without
without 60 votes so a lot can happen in
terms of Obama's long term agenda if the
democrats retain control the senate and
it's not clear what those judicial
appointments are going to look like and
what those confirmations are going to
look like with republican control big
republicans will diffuse the nuclear
option they're going to keep the the
current rules I don't know what kind of
judges yeah yes and I don't know what
kind of judge what kind of judges Obama
will get through maybe we may be in the
audience have more judicial experts than
I but I don't know what that what will
that would look like they're the only
other thing that I'm attentive to is the
changing of the south and and you look
at North Carolina Georgia places you
know places where the Democrats might
win but they also just might retain
seats and there's certainly just more
competition in these states than than
we've seen before we have a lot of new
migrants to this area and I wonder
whether we know we know partisanship is
a pretty big pull in either direction
but but i wonder if southern
competitiveness will be a moderating
force for any of the senators who are
from kind of the north part of the south
davis excuse me yes back to buy six
presidents again briefly there there is
across them there is there there is no
instance of a president in his they're
all his is fourth Congress pursuing and
getting enacted getting enacted a
domestic legislative program it is a
zero there's just nothing there nothing
the however these last Congress's have
been if you just look at the items put
on the books that are reasonably
important there's a good deal of
legislating it takes place it's just not
easy to predict what will come up during
the two years but compromise legislation
of various sorts like banking reform on
and Clinton's last Congress or the
reorganized the railroads entirely and
Wilson's last kind so on Nancy Pelosi at
a program in 07 08 which was pushed 43 s
last Congress they raised the minimum
wage in 1907 2007-2008 Democrats took to
Congress and they did that Bush signed
it in two thousand two thousand eight
seven to eight and so forth I think that
I think what I just said holds
regardless of whether the Republicans
take over the Senate it's a pattern for
last Congress as regardless of that if
the Republicans do take over the Senate
I think that agenda control makes a fair
amount of difference that is any the
position taking cubed will come into
effect with the with the
republican-controlled Senate either to
try to enact things so to set up issues
for the 2016 election or just plain to
get the message across period in some
general sense that will be there it's
the the yes I mean after all Harry Reid
and this current Congress has muffled
most disagreement on the Senate floor
most this agreement they would have
obtained anyway among Democrats just
just shut down the Senate more or less
now it will either open up where we shut
down in a different way but if if if if
McConnell becomes later and wants to
X exercise the same degree of agenda
control maybe you can do it if you can
get around Ted Cruz if he has a small
majority good luck dealing with Ted Cruz
but whether I'd want to do that I don't
know he may prevent some a little more
openness and reach things reaching the
floor Boehner did when he took over from
Pelosi a little bit more stuff reaching
the floor at least early on in two
thousand and two thousand and two
thousand and eleven we really don't know
I would think the Republicans if they do
take over the Senate and they've got the
house then they want for one thing
they'll put their heads together and try
to present themselves in a fashion that
doesn't make them look ridiculous and I
do that Delta muscle there folks
actually if Boehner get some more seats
in the house that will help baynard's
control of the house as they take over
10 or 12 seats that would help that is
that some of the folks come again are
pretty ferocious the new Republicans but
still some of those things going out are
pretty ferocious too i would think if
Boehner gets Boehner bit going to be
very happy if he gets another eight or
ten seats something like that I would
think it would help control I think that
what they may do what they are trying to
do that they talking about doing among
other things is to try to put through
some modestly important instruments that
could get through the Senate and maybe
the president would sign or have
difficulty vetoing like getting rid of
the medical devices tax for example
they're talking about that i would guess
they dip through in a hurry nacked meant
to to build the keystone pipeline i
think probably a clinton brenton Clinton
Obama would veto that probably he would
if he didn't bill mckibben would have
cardiac arrest there's a you have to
beat so the Keystone pipeline there's so
much pressure there from the from the
greetings i think but it will go on like
that i think i mean there is a range of
issues on which a party controlling the
Senate can pick up some votes from the
opposition for example the bush tax cuts
in 2001 they got up to about 60 votes
the Republicans had only 50 but I mean a
sweetened the whole business is a
committee process and I think finally
they got about 60 didn't they for the
bush tax cuts something like that I
think we'll probably see some of that
Cheney had to cast the decisive votes on
the procedural matters so they obviously
weren't quite there they needed that for
sure yeah so then hmm let me get veto
back and forth
one of the patterns is Vito games we'll
probably see that but sometimes these
Vito games it would do emanate in some
enactments idea well we just have to see
but I think and for the most part of the
legislative course of the two years is
unpredictable if you look at any two
year period up front you'll see that
that's the way things are well I'll have
just two quick thoughts and then I want
to open it up I mean one is that whether
or not the Republicans are capable of
putting up these these relatively
popular or at least popular among big
donors like the medical device tax
issues is going to depend I think on the
size of their Senate Majority and so
you're right more seats for Boehner will
be helpful but also I think they're
going to have a harder time if they're
really close to 50 in the in the Senate
coming up with some with things that can
garner a strong enough support from
their caucus I'm the other thing I was
just going to say maybe it's obvious but
and you might be able to tell me whether
it is the historical pattern but from
the standpoint of the Democrats it's not
entirely clear that it's a bad thing to
have the house and the Senate in
Republican hands and obviously a lot
would depend on how those video games
play out whether or not it's favorable
towards the Democratic presidential
prospects in 2016 so what does the
history show on that David's I don't
know i i've seen some polling data back
i think John would know I think that
some polling data they're having it that
presidents tend to ride higher in the
polls if they've got an opposition
Congress the blame will get shared
worthy after I think there's something
but does that redound to the benefit of
party in the next presidential election
for the next election you know I would
guess not I would guess that it washes
out I would guess I really don't know I
mean they say that Trent did truman and
48 benefited from being able to attack
the 80th congress in 47 48 clinton in
90s i think probably at overhyped with
trumpeted 48 i guess i really don't
believe it that it made that much
difference in plenty 96 well they're
both sides got hills I mean yes or
Clinton did cooperative games with a
gingrich in that congress of 95 90
62 the benefit I think of both House
Republicans and the Clinton Democrats in
the White House both of them yeah it's
an odd kind of write positive gave very
very uncooperative games it 95 but in 96
they switched to cooperation ok well
let's open it up and you know just
please speak clearly for the video and
for us and I'll try to just call them
people and so raise your hands if you're
interested ask you a question they are
in the back yeah just wondering about
what impact do you think immigration
reform or the lack of agrarian reform
will have on the ditches did you reset
the questions one of you do certain say
he's wondering what what impact
immigration reform or rather it's lack
will have might have on the midterms
none I mean it seems to me that the
parties are clearly positioned such that
say Latino Americans know where parties
stand relative to one another Democrats
aren't making this a priority they
pretty much never have so you know it's
a question of whether you know if if the
Democrats had put it on the agenda a
little bit higher on the agenda earlier
in the Obama yours would this have been
a more of a mobilizing force for Latinos
or not I'm not sure yeah your question
right here in the front we're talking a
lot about Democrats versus Republicans
in terms of the control the House Senate
and so forth but we also see as part of
the Citizens United ruling that now
because there's more flush with money
perhaps we see people funding candidates
according to their new tissues i'm
thinking like tom steyer for instance
who's funding primarily Democrats who
are willing to stand up for
environmental issues can we talk about
the death narrative out a bit and talk
about like how that might impact the
control
and the senate or who might get elected
for the midterms or in subsequent years
well I i love this is united ruling have
because it's produced all this great you
know advertising and and debate among
candidates of different and you know
this is not right there's no donations
to candidates it's just people spending
money outside Democrats and Republicans
both creating super PACs where they're
trying to sell voters on their side and
it doesn't you know that I don't think
we can point to any situation in this
election or any suit any election
basically we're where we can point to
some outside group changing polls
dramatically but the two sides are
competing and they're competing through
these outside groups and you know for
everyone's benefit is anybody have a
descending view on that first on the
panel men in the audience though no okay
and also do you mean so in other words a
time you don't foresee the ability of
donors to kind of bankroll candidates
you know the sheldon adelson effect if
you will as really changing anything
fundamental about american elections
right yeah i mean right because because
i think there's parity and party
platform phone
important as like in other words if Tom
Steyer also started back in a Republican
who was in a hotly contested district
because that Republican was willing to
stand for environmental issue so I'll
just make one comment and I'll go to you
you definitely want to say something
that parody in observed outcomes is not
the same as saying that the people who
run or the positions they take aren't
influenced by money of politics right
because obviously if if the if this
affects recruitment processes or what
issues candidates feel like that to run
on to get money it's going to be you
know beneath the surface and influence
on the political arena and then the
other thing I would say is just that you
know one wonder is whether or not the so
that questioning the efficiency of a lot
of this campaign spending but one
wonders whether or not the incentives
for candidates are so strongly to take
kind of negative positions not towards
not just toward their opponents but also
toured the institution as a whole that
that might not have some effect over the
longer term as more money comes into
politics but anyway you're I want to ask
about the citizens united into all this
outside money and the effect it might
have on
of our traditional indicators of voter
behavior things like turnout voter
information willingness to respond to
polls willingness to participate in
campaigns are we seeing any evidence of
effects on some of those indicators I
can speak to the polling side of that
and we're not seeing anything specific
that we can tie to citizens united or
funding what the big focus in pulling
for response is the fact that people
don't and this is why you see such large
debates in the polling and survey
research world about method how they're
getting the interviews if you're using
phones well are you calling cell phones
are you calling enough cell phones
because so many people are going cell
phone only well that gets expensive
because the FCC says you can't auto dial
a cell phone you also can't robo call a
cell phone so anybody who uses robo
polls can't do that and switching to
online is fraught with issues as well
you have instead of asking people to
take a survey you have people that are
opting in so response rates are very low
with all methods practically besides
face-to-face where somebody walks up to
you and says please answer my questions
that's still a little more successful
but as far as that goes the that's where
the focus is I don't think we can narrow
it down you know when we only have five
to nine percent response rates for most
polls I don't think it's really possible
at this point to narrow it down to why
people aren't responding but it is an
interesting question for sure almost add
that there's a there's a there's a
there's a lot of studies out of negative
advertising on elections and one thing
that the super PACs do similar to how
the big party committees act is that the
candidates will have positive apps and
they'll just say nothing and adds one
half the other saying you know I care
about education and the economy and but
say nothing about policy it's really a
negative ads where you have some policy
information but
really is the expert on this so maybe he
should say something about it but in
general if it's true that politie Bad's
are a little bit more informative
because they talk a little bit more
about policy than positive ads I know
there's some debate about this it's the
super PACs on the party committees that
are running those negative those
negative ads more the only other thing
I'll just add is that right if you're a
candidate and if super PAC decides to
run ads in your race that's not
necessarily great for you there's some
there are some conditions under which
he'll be a bad thing one is that you
don't really trust this super PAC to do
the right thing you or not you know you
don't know who they are you don't they
care about some niche issue that you
don't care about and you don't
necessarily want the election of me
about that issue so it's not necessarily
great for the candidate it's also from
the voters perspective you know if
you're in a standard congressional
election where typically there are no
ads run because in most congressional
elections there are no ads on TV and
then all of a sudden there's an influx
of ads you know voters might be
skeptical but who are these outside
groups who why are there people focusing
on us and so I don't think it came to
the extent that super PACs candidates
and parties are being strategic about
their use of money and outside money in
politics they don't have a lot of
evidence to you know on which to be very
strategic so I would just say a couple
quick things in response that question I
mean one is we do know that the that the
slight as money has become more as the
amount of money going into the elections
has gone up and really for many years I
mean you have a you know until they're
schneider at all wrote a piece and you
know back in two thousand where they
showed that the trends were not that
sharply upward but since then they're
sort of like like the standard political
scientists writing about something just
before it changes you know the soviet
union will persist forever and and so
we're now catching up with the reality
that there's been an enormous increase
in the amount of money going in to
campaigns and at the same time as that's
happened the share of that money coming
from the top echelon of American
societies also increased so between
nineteen eighty four 2012 the share of
campaign contributions coming from the
top point one percent so the top one in
a thousand households has risen from
around twelve percent to forty percent
so that's a pretty remarkable
shift whether it how it's changed the
kinds of issues or our positions that
are taken is another is another matter
the other thing I would say is just in
light I i think that's that's probably
true at a time saying about negative ads
having more information and my point was
only that and I think this is more
generally true and interesting as sort
of the valence of people's feelings
towards political institutions groans
for negative the incentive to sort of
degrade the collective good of positive
feelings towards public authority
increases and so the negative ads are
just part of that larger trend I think
of running for political institutions by
running against political institutions
and I think you know underlying some of
the political challenges we face today
is basically a crisis of authority the
difficulty of because of polarization
but also because of this cross partisan
incentive to undermine the basis for
legitimate public action the the sort of
decline in general sense of faith in our
political institutions and the only
other thing I would say is I haven't
seen a lot of good over time data on
this but the polling really suggests
that people are very negative about the
amount of money in politics so political
scientists tend to be very sanguine and
Americans tend to be very alarmist about
political money and I wonder if the
correct position is somewhere between
the voters and the political scientists
here David you have a thought yeah I do
ever thought if you look at the history
of campaign finance reform or efforts to
achieve reform over a century and a half
it is a succession of palliation zuv
perceived problems and the problems of
variations late 19th century it was a
public officials getting fleeced by the
parties that was a problem which
produced a bad bureaucracy among other
things in the 20th century it shifted to
the problem shifted to corporations
dumping money into politics and that
lasted most of the century in the mid
20th century there was a fair amount of
worry about unions putting a lot of
money into politics but right now it
seems to me this is a big difference is
it's a billionaires problem and notice a
billionaires problem or a perceived
problem is
be different from a problem of
corporations putting money into politics
it's billionaires and I think it seems
to smell bad billionaire is being able
to put Billy an awful lot of money into
politics i would guess it give it 10 to
15 years and this will get changed
somehow that is that either through its
or both but it through statutes through
new Supreme Court appointments through
constitutional reform whatever I would
guess that the perceived billionaires
problem is going to get addressed nice I
first of all I have to say palliation
zuv perceived problems is is the best
alliteration we've had yet someone has
to tweet that polska mania scaly ations
of perceived problems might even be
better I'll only say if you're
interested in this question of what
difference that might make is so if
money does have some effect in terms of
influence you might read the recent
issue of perspectives with the bartells
page see right survey of the super rich
in chicago area suggesting that they do
the rich are different from ewing me
they're generally speaking more
conservative so but the bridge who are
donating some of the prominent ones are
actually quite liberal so its overall I
think perhaps somewhat more balanced
than the modal position say of the
American rich if we know what that is
Joe and then how could you I have a
question for David in the last midterm
you mentioned that unlike other
comparable midterms the dems did lose a
few seats in the Senate yes I'm talking
about the Senate now do you think that
this may in fact alleviate the magnitude
of loss if there is going to be any next
Tuesday worried about that that's
possible because after all the figures
are across the whole Senate a whole
hundred so it's it's possible something
is something yeah so maybe maybe I don't
know how to think about that i mean the
intervals around what I'm talking about
is so white anyway is difficult to know
but I said interesting question yes
controlling for something like a
national mood and I know that you don't
by others Dave and the presents pretty
pretty unpopular everywhere I mean with
a few exceptions but you see racist like
jeanne shaheen Dan Malloy races that you
this shouldn't be close to our maybe
like the other rate since I can't take
in mark Pryor and Arkansas that should
be a runaway for Republicans but aren't
so if there isn't something that that
you can capture like a national mood is
there anything systemic then you can add
to the model that explains this
variation or is it purely just
state-by-state release my race is there
anything national you can capture is
essentially whether or not we I mean
they're actually two questions here so I
want to sort of chase them out too so
one is a pleasant as a modeling question
right and that depend and and and the
modeling question would be do you need
some variable for the national mood
versus just individual polls and and I
think that would partly hinge on the
extent to which we believe in predicting
the election outcomes with polls is
easier obviously than predicting
election outcomes with say fundamentals
like you know the state of the economy
predicting the question would be how
much the polling is incorporating that
national mood so that that's a
forecasting question but the more analyt
analytically and politically interesting
question is is what's playing out in
terms of a national mood this year so
whether it's getting incorporated into
the local pols whether you need another
variable putting that aside what's going
on you know this seems like a pretty
anti obama tide and yet you do see these
states where where republicans are much
more vulnerable than we would have
expected and yes of course we also see
lots of places where as expected
Republicans are crunk no crushing so i'm
curious what people think about what's
the larger picture here Natalie so it's
interesting where these things are
happening of a ton mentioned the south
and we have two major southern races in
Louisiana and Arkansas where Democrat
incumbents are likely to lose so in that
way you kind of see what you would
expect shifting over to what is
happening you know it's kind of amazing
that you had the Democratic incumbent
and there are a couple of other seats
where South Dakota West Virginia and
Montana where longtime Democrats did not
run again or it's an open seat in some
other way so I'm showing you know 99
percent probabilities that the
Republicans win but then we have Georgia
and Kentucky suddenly where the
Democrats are competitive including in
Kentucky against McConnell I would argue
that race is basically over and that
McConnell probably has it in hand but
it's been very competitive so what's
happening nationally is not necessarily
uniform and this is actually an argument
in forecasting as well you know should
we allow states to correlate well in a
presidential election certainly because
you're combining everything to get to
one estimate but when we're talking
about the Senate do we expect patterns
in one state to affect patterns in the
other state and I actually did some
analysis on this in back testing our
model in 2006 and 2010 and found
moderate correlations between the states
but nothing really to make me think that
I needed to build that into the model as
far as putting the fundamentals in it's
a my question with fundamentals in a
model and with any variable in any model
is does it actually make a difference
does it make it fundamentally better to
over use the word fundamental and does
it make a better model and I haven't
seen all that much in the forecasting
I'm sway bull I'll show me the evidence
and I'll look at it and but I haven't
seen that much that says that
fundamentals are what control the
prediction of the forecast even in the
Washington Post model the monkey cage
model that John sides and Eric McGee
have put together they have the
fundamentals phasing out so over time
they had the polls gaining more and more
weight in their model to I think their
final split is 85 15 and 5 38 in New
York Times the other major models that
included fundamentals did something
similar I don't know the exact
proportions on theirs but so so I just
want to jump in there and say I think
that one reason that one the reason I
mentioned fundamentals wasn't whether
they should be put in forecasting models
it was to draw us back to the
distinction between a forecasting model
in an explanatory or causal model right
so it's relatively easy to predict
revolutions when the armed
revolutionaries arrived at the gates but
it and by the same token it's relatively
I'm not saying easy I'm not going to do
this you do it much better than I do but
if we know what the polls are week
before the election we probably could do
pretty well in predicting the election
the that doesn't that but what's what's
in what's influencing those polls is
obviously the question right and I'm for
causal analysis and and I'm not actually
sure what the causal status of the front
what we call the fundamentals are in
congressional elections I tend to
believe from much of the forecasting
stuff I've seen that doesn't include
polls is that that actually elect
economic conditions aren't particularly
good in the midterm context as compared
with the presidential election so I was
on I just want to clarify that so yeah
but I think that and you may have
response so i do actually i think that's
an important point to make that and with
a lot of what goes on in the forecasting
world these are produced for media and
public consumption and what hasn't
happened so far that I think we
desperately need is the type of post hoc
research
what works really well you know if
somebody wants a dissertation topic here
you go and what what really works who's
really doing the best or any kind of
good job with these models and we have
evidence you know back testing etc that
I did that shows the polls are pretty
good even about four to five months out
but we need that kind of research that
would inform that question David 2017
yeah two points one is that I think
Senate elections are to something really
like presidential elections are good
with Tory electrons or big city mayor
elections and that the point candidate
specific after all people there's a lot
of face time there in television debates
people tend to know what the candidates
are so things generally speaking will
attend to even though there will be a
lot of error so to speak in whatever
you're doing in the way of model link
that that will accrue to the candidate
characteristics of the candidates I just
seems right i mean take this year for
example i mean Jody your instance doing
very well in Iowa but the Republican
candidates of land and Webbie and in
Michigan and Aragon are not doing very
well and everybody says quite credibly
it has to do with candidate
characteristics there it is that's point
number one point number two is that it's
this issue incumbency and i'm not sure
where I'm going on this one but in come
and see is in sort of help to run again
as an incumbent I think at the house
level the answer is on average well yes
I mean help statistically it helps you
to win again if you run it as a newcomer
for example I think one reason are
carrying this out for this disparity
which 810 talked about a 2012 between
the National House vote and national
House seat winnings is that the
Republicans had a whole flock of people
who were new who are running as
incumbents and who benefited from that I
mean it they won in 2010 here are some
statistics in 2010 the Republicans
selected a whole lot of new people there
are about fifty five of those people who
took seats from Democrats in 2010 and
ran again as Republicans against
Democrats in 2012 okay that's a lot of
people at the same time that the whole
country was shifting between 2000 and
2012 in a democratic direction in the
National Household by about four percent
among these 55 the National House vote
was switching two percent in a
Republican direction between 2010 2012
which means these people working six
percent against the trend as you go from
one election who don't know which is
really something I mean incumbents they
can raise money they can do stuff now I
think I would I really don't know I
think maybe that doesn't work so well in
the Senate side I haven't seen anybody
model this now with house elections
Erickson and his folks at Columbia at
modeling house elections if got have got
one instrument where they where they
where they take into account whether the
house seats are open that is to say
encumbrance running again or not that as
they plug that into modeling I am
sitting to when he done that with do
that with the Senate elections and just
to confuse things they really do know
that Senate incumbents could lose the
main Texas six-year year ago as a small
car load of Republican incumbents it was
six years ago to dump res we know that
we know that on the other hand two years
ago at 2012 32 Senate incumbents Rena
November ballot the only one on the laws
with Scott Brown who'd never faced an
even to your electorate before it's got
brown they all the others they wrecked
it up in 2012 and in Arkansas me that
probably would not be a close race this
year if Pryor would decide to take his
pension there probably would that be
probably that's true so I just said I
haven't seen this model of the Senate
side yes that's great oh yeah Laurie
I've always wondered if anybody has
studied whether polls themselves in the
influencing voter turnout or how people
vote by having them see the polls and
say oh no my candidate is losing having
to go vote or oh my candidate ends I so
much I don't bother there's a very
recently published article i believe
it's by david Rothschild and Neil
mehrotra on exactly that and I haven't
had a chance to read the whole thing had
a few other things happening and but
from my quick skim of it there say they
do find evidence of that happening it's
not an overwhelming amount but um I
would definitely look that up because
people are very actively looking into
that right now I'll just add one little
factoid which is a while ago 30 years
ago there was a state senator in
California named Caribbean I think was
his name whoo-hoo proposed a state law
to that you weren't allowed to publish
pulls ahead of the election so that
voters won't be influenced by the polls
obvious he's not constitutional thing to
do but but but yeah that was that was
there people have been concerned about
that for a while great that's so curtain
right there are is probably always but a
couple prominent Louisiana Senate the
main governor where I independent or
third-party candidates a factor major
spoiler factor what trends are there and
predictions you may have four people
voting for other than two major parties
well that's a question I've been looking
at a lot in the last couple of weeks
primarily dealing with Georgia's Senate
race and it looks like the Libertarian
candidate is pulling just enough to make
that not to make Purdue who's leading or
not either one of them could take it
it's going to prevent either of them
from reaching fifty percent and Georgia
does have that fifty percent threshold
as does Louisiana Louisiana is a little
bit more complex because of the jungle
primary and where everybody's running at
once but um we certainly see it in
Georgia and the outcome there is
basically that right now as it stands
nuns chances would be better if she
could win on november four and when we
go to a runoff situation things tilt a
little bit more toward Purdue and we
actually built the calculation at the
end of last week to calculate the
probability of a runoff and the
probability of a win and it stays on
produce side both ways right now we're
looking at about a fifty six percent
chance of a runoff and the other case is
Maine which had X
they had a little movement yesterday
where the third candidate said basically
vote your conscience and because it was
kind of the realization that he's
pulling votes away from I believe it's
the Democrat I'm not an expert on main
I'm sorry um and so that has the
potential to throw rice Kansas was a big
deal this year I think we all know the
narrative there so we're we're seeing
actually it feels to me like more of
that this cycle where the third
candidates are spoilers we have a little
bit of it here in Connecticut even
though i think rhetorically Malloy is
hurt but a third candidate but I think
politically Foley is the any other
questions yes so the potential new
candidates or the house or the Senate
who do you think would be the most
interesting or potentially have the most
impact its
what's interesting though can attain
success yeah interesting you candidates
David are you fine I was I mean or you
know Orman is this weird case so that so
that this is a Kansas right we're so
it's a non Democrat who's running
against the Republican and hasn't
committed to which party will caucus
with and there's a good chance that you
know come Wednesday of next week no one
had any idea what's happening and a lot
of potentially focused on which party
gordmans going to caucus with which
makes him interesting in the immediate
future but also long term if he's going
to be kind of a rogue a rogue entity in
terms of cultural candidates newton news
members of the Senate who will be
interesting to watch I mean we don't
have any Ted Cruz's coming in doing I
don't think so they're pretty no bomb
thrower boring I think what the watch
would be nobody pays the intention of
this guy Ben Sasse of Nebraska it's
going to be Republican senator replacing
a Republican we're not even watching
that race but he's very interesting
character or college president very
talented and possibly ambitious i yes by
the way i'm in new senators there'll be
a lot of regardless who takes the Senate
it'll be a lot of new Republican
senators I looked in it the other day
they'll be maybe in double digits and do
Republican senators where there may be
very few new democratic senators it has
to do with retirements and such I will
say the one thing on to pay attention to
among those Republican senators is Rand
Paul ish foreign policy because not much
is going to happen to send domestically
but the Senate will have some things to
say about foreign policy the presumed
Democratic nominee on the Democratic
side is the most hawkish person to run
for president on the Democratic side in
a long time and so both as a matter of
differentiation and because it's
interesting the Republicans are going to
have a debate about this and and no one
I don't think there's not a lot of
serious consideration to Rand Paul being
the next eventual
lookin nominee but there's a there's a
heck of a lot of room for him to get
support from people who are
uncomfortable on both sides or the
hawkish nests of Hillary Clinton any
more questions yes John I just wanted to
return to the money points a little bit
good maybe states of conjecture get the
panel's thoughts on this so money's only
really valuable work where a campaign or
when it campaigns expensive and some one
thing that's changing is that most or
much of advertising currently on TV may
shift other resources like the Internet
where virtually it's pretty cost less to
reach people but admittedly the effects
might be small some wondering if we
should be worried about money at nine
cents worth of money in another sense
which is candidates candidates but
outside groups influencing elections in
other ways like get-out-the-vote efforts
targeting particular places where they
may have partisan supporters and higher
numbers I mean yeah this is not yeah my
view on this not about given the
evidence my view is just that the more
the merrier I I don't see any reason to
be concerned about this both sides are
using a lot of resources to try to
influence elections because I care about
elections and there's lots of different
kinds of groups the billionaire's Club
who's engaging in politics is really
diverse set of people who care about
specific issues and some care about the
environment and some care about gay
marriage and some care about point
pipelines and you know they're all
trying to engage with the electorate hey
this is that nice based on personal
observation and I live in a swing
district in New York at both the
congressional and the local levels I
can't log into Facebook without being
inundated with ads I don't think I've
seen a non-political Facebook ad in
weeks and so I think the more powerful
place for that like I said that I've
done no research on this at all but it
seems to me like the more powerful place
for that would be the local races our
state Senate race is basically being
played out online
and John have one more thought which is
given I think they're very steeply
diminishing marginal returns for
spending and I so I think your
conjecture is right that as as as if
campaigning if the options if television
advertising is is less and less
effective money is going to go elsewhere
but the other thing is to think about
groups going for lower hanging fruit we
heard there's this time series times
piece on the Attorney General's you know
the way in which the coke network is
focused on state legislators seems
interesting to me there so vessel has
been writing vessel is here but yeah she
left she's vessel weaver it's been
writing a little bit about this so I
would expect another thing you're gonna
see is not just other ways of spending
money but more and more thinking about
okay what's the pipeline of candidates
how do you influence lower level policy
developments you know how you know the
first wave of this was really about how
to you insolent state legislature so you
can affect read it as redistricting but
you know there's a lot of other things
you can do there are a lot of notes of
power in the American political system
and a lot of them have until recently
had almost no money and very little
non-financial political activity and I
think that's changing and that will
contribute to the nationalization
because much much of this is going to be
coming from groups that are aligned with
the kind of the national political
cleavage I feel as if we should probably
wrap up david has a thought and then I
have a closing remarks so very brief
started back to John Deere point an
interesting new characters breasts
they're coming in another one is Tom
cotton of Arkansas if he wins as I think
Tom cotton of Arkansas bents assets SAS
se of Nebraska who may both be new
Republican senators are especially
talented and ambitious people that is I
think we may be looking at folks who
want to do better than the Senate in
those instances I'm will shake in what's
ass is up to but I think maybe that's
right so we'll keep our eyes out for
them we'll think about that this these
wonderful perspectives as we watch the
the races unfold and before november
fourth and I think it's pretty fair to
say I'd want to initially do an election
night event
but given the current forecast for
recounts and the like I think it's
probably a good thing that we're having
this in advance because it may be a very
long night and actually several days so
in this not I hope very long seeming
exchange I think we've gone a great
preview of what to look for both during
and after the election i want to thank
and i hope you'll join me in thanking
this wonderful group of panelists